[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes sur le chantier du pavillon
réciproque le pavillon réciproque donc
les construit par le pea paris-saclay
sur la place marguerite père et où nous
sommes qui constitue l'espace public
principale du quartier l'école
polytechnique on a fait le constat en
fait partager avec l'ensemble des
usagers que le campus manqué de lieux un
peu neutre qui soit pas rattachés à une
entreprise ou à une école ou un
établissement et donc on avait ce besoin
en fait de construire des lieux qui
puisse accueillir les différents publics
et qu'ils puissent être à la disposition
de tout le monde et on puisse constituer
des lieux de rencontre et donc nous
avons décidé de construire ce pavillon
qui en fait un pavillon temporaire c'est
à dire qu' il va être démontée d'ici
deux à trois ans on a également souhaité
que ce pavillon soit construit dans le
cadre d'un chantier participatif ça veut
dire que les constructeurs le groupement
depuis 1920 quidam et 14 qui sont
spécialisés et dans la construction bois
et dans l'organisation de chantier
participatif
ouvre certaines parties du chantier à la
co-construction avec les usagers donc
concrètement on a lancé un appel à
l'ensemble des personnes qui composent
le campus de pouvoir revenir sur
certaines plages horaires nous aider ce
chantier participatif s'achève là donc
il a duré 15 jours et on a un prochain
chantier participatif qui va se dérouler
du 2 au 6 mai pour construire ce qu'on
appelle le lanterneau qui va être en
fait un petit édifice en bois qui va
surmonter le pavillon dans sa forme
finale
et on est très fiers de participer à ce
projet et sous le triptyque et des
bénévoles de ce projet et partager nos
savoir faire autour des constructions
bois donc sur ce projet au bout d'une
semaine voire dix jours maintenant on a
eu des profils des bénévoles très
diverses
avec qui on a passé de très bons moments
de partage de convivialité et aussi de
transmission qui est très important pour
nous de faire participer les gens dans
le processus de construction et
et partager cette moment merveilleux
voilà
le pavillon réciproque sera ouvert à
l'ensemble des usagers du campus soit
sous forme de location soit faux sous
forme de mise à disposition il sera
inauguré le 21 juin donc j'invite tous
ceux qui souhaitent venir à l'occasion
de la fête de la musique assisté à
l'inauguration du pavillon est donc ce
sera l'occasion de tester pour la
première fois le pavillon et notamment
en accueillant des groupes de musique
issus des associations enfin des tissus
associatifs étudiants du campus mais
également avec un certain nombre
d'ateliers en collaboration avec la
ville de palaiseau et en particulier le
service jeunesse et le service culture
[Musique]